en tu cuestionario de mate gana 5 puntos
por cada pregunta que respondes
correctamente en la tabla de abajo x
representa el número de preguntas que
contestas correctamente en tu
cuestionario y ya representa el número
total de puntos que obtienes en tu
cuestionario la relación entre estas dos
variables puede ser expresada por la
siguiente ecuación igual a 5x gráfica la
ecuación abajo para esto podemos tomar
un par de puntos si tenemos cero
respuestas correctas tenemos cero puntos
grafica mos entonces ese punto tengo
cero respuestas correctas tengo cero
puntos y si tengo una respuesta correcta
nos lo da la tabla o podemos pensar que
cada respuesta correcta nos da cinco
puntos así es que por una respuesta
correcta tenemos cinco puntos así es que
si tengo una respuesta correcta
voy a tener cinco puntos esto lo vemos
también la tabla una respuesta correcta
cinco puntos también podemos graficar
dos respuestas correctas diez puntos
cualquiera de estos puntos sirve solo se
necesitan dos puntos para definir una
recta así es que parece que aquí ya
hemos terminado